Clawed code sucks at front-end design
and it's your fault. But this is a
problem we can solve with a simple road
map. You just got to know where you're
going. And in this video, I'm going to
break down the seven levels to clawed
code front-end design and explain what
you can expect at each level, the traps
to avoid, and what you need to do to
progress to the next one. And by the
end, you will have a simple, repeatable
process to create front-end designs with
cloud code that aren't yet another
generic, boring template. Now, our case
study for today's video is going to be
our fake SAS web app known as Argus.
Argus is going to be a social media
intelligence application. So,
essentially a place that content
creators or really whoever can go to and
find trending topics in their niche. And
it is through Argus. You're going to go
through the entire sevenle process. So,
let's begin with level one. And sadly, a
lot of people are actually stuck here.
This is just you and a prompt. You're
going to have Claude code open and
you're just going to say something like,
"Hey, let's create a landing page for
Argus, my social media web app that acts
as an intelligence app for content
creators to find and identify trending
topics in their niche." Now, even if I
do this and I put it into plan mode,
what we are going to get is something
very, very generic. Why? because we've
really given it no design direction and
we're kind of relying on clawed code to
fill in the gaps of like what looks
good. You hear this often like AI has no
taste. True, but actually most people
have no taste and because of that
problem, they can't articulate it to
Claude code, right? If you don't know
what right looks like, how is Claude
Code supposed to figure it out? So what
it is here at the most base level that
we need to begin to master a few skills
and those three skills are writing
descriptive prompts, specifying
frameworks and understanding what these
frameworks even are, and then beginning
to build a basic design vocabulary. Now,
by simply using plan mode in this
process, you're going to begin to build
some of these skills because it's going
to ask you questions like, "What text
stack do you want to use for this
landing page?" Right? Next.js, plain
HTML, Astro. You're going to have no
clue what any of these mean. But by
simply typing something asking what are
these frameworks right you're going to
begin to build some level of competence
in this space when it comes to
frameworks and things like this you just
have to ask questions plan mode is also
going to force you to think about design
decisions and the actual goal of your
website because it's not enough to say
hey I just want a landing page for Argus
what is the point of this right what is
the actual outcome you are shooting for
in this case we want both a weight list
signup and a product showcase and then
it's going to explicitly ask us
questions about style. Now, right away,
you know, these sorts of visual styles
it's going to give you again are kind of
generic, dark and techy, clean and
minimal, right? Like this isn't specific
enough to really get the outcomes we
want. Yet, this is where everyone stays
at. And this is why everything looks so
generic. So, for us, we'll go ahead and
we'll do clean and minimal. And then
we'll just do the hero, the features,
and a call to action and submit this
guy. Now, you're probably thinking,
"Hey, if this is all super basic, how am
I actually going to write descriptive
prompts and build that basic design
vocabulary?" Well, frankly, it's going
to just take some time and it's going to
take experience. The more you are
exposed to, again, what right looks
like, creative front-end designs, the
more you're going to pick up on these
things, and we'll talk about that more
in future levels. So, let's take a look
at what it built us. And holy AI slob,
this is hideous, right? This is as
generic as it gets. We even have the
purple gradients which AI absolutely
loves for some reason. So what happened?
What went wrong? Even with plan mode,
this is what we got. Well, the truth is,
like you already know, Claude code and
AI in general isn't the best at
front-end design. And if you give it
sort of non-escriptive, boring prompts,
this is the sort of output you're going
to get, right? And yet, this is what you
tend to see all over the place with
maybe a few differences. So, what can we
do? What can we do to get out of level
one and get out of design hell? But
before we do that, a quick word from
everybody's favorite sponsor, me. So, I
just released the Claude Code Masterass
not too long ago, and it is the number
one place to go from zero to AI dev,
especially if you don't come from a
technical background. I update this
every week, and since its release, we've
already added over an hour of new
content and updated 20 plus modules. So,
if you want to get your hands on it, you
can find it in Chase AI Plus. There's a
link to that in the pin comment. But if
you're brand new to AI, that's just a
bridge too far. Make sure to check out
the free Chase AI community. There's a
link to that in the description. Well,
to move on to level two, we need to give
Claude a design education. And this is
where we begin to bring in skills. This
is where we start bringing outside
specialized prompts that tell Claude
code how to design better. Now, these
skills we rely on like the front-end
design skill and the UIUX Pro Max skill
are going to do a lot of the heavy
lifting for us. they are going to inject
clawed code with these prompts that say,
"Hey, if you're creating a web page in
this industry, here's the sort of things
you could be looking for. Here's a list
of all like the AI slop design
techniques. Avoid these." So,
essentially, it's going to supercharge
our problems even if we show up with
something that's rather poor. And here's
a look at that UIUX Pro Max skill. This
is an open source repo on GitHub. It's
got 52,000 stars. We can go inside of
here in the skills folder and actually
see how everything is set up if we want
to. Right? It's all just text prompts
and it's a bunch of text prompts that
are acting like a checklist for claude
code to again get it out of this generic
stuff so we don't get stuck with this.
Now to install this particular skill and
all other skills like it. It's very
simple. If we go inside the GitHub, we
have instructions laid out for us right
here. We're just going to do forward
slashplugin marketplace add the skill
and then install the skill. So we just
run this inside of our cloud code
terminal. And if that is a bit too
confusing, understand you can always
just copy paste the URL of this, dump it
into cloud code and say, "Hey, I would
like to install this skill." So let's
put this skill to the test. I've loaded
the skill with a forward slash. You can
also use natural language and say
something like, "Hey, Cloud Code, use
the UIUX Promax skill." And we're going
to say, "I want you to recreate the
landing page using the skill, asking any
questions you need." Now, similar to
standard Cloud Code plan mode, it's
going to ask us some questions about the
style. We'll do what it recommends this
time, right? Going for some typography.
Sure, sounds great. And then a CTA
color. Let's do orange. We want to get
away from the purple at all costs. So,
Cloud Code finished the redesign. So,
let's take a look. So, here's the
landing page using the UIUX Pro Max
skill. And right away, this is a huge
improvement, right? We actually have
like a proper background and add this
little square thing. The buttons
themselves have like a subtle glow and
they even change color when you mouse
over them. We have a graphic and the
colors change from section to section.
So, this is way, way better, even though
it's still it absolutely loves the
purple. That being said, this is clearly
made by AI, right? This isn't something
that you would see and be blown away
with what was created. This still looks
like an AI template. Looks like a
designed AI template, but this is still
an AI template. And at its core, it's
the same exact website you kind of saw
before, which is a little bit of window
dressing. So, how can we actually
improve this? How can we move out of
level two into level three? Because
these skills are great. They are
bringing some ideas of color theory and
typography, spacing, and just general
layout design. But at its core, right,
this is still generic. And the truth is
when it comes to the skills to master,
the biggest one is like how do we
evaluate this output with a designer's
eye and then turn those critiques into
prompts. This is still a prompting
problem. But the issue with prompting,
and this is where we get into the
trapped here, is like there is a ceiling
to how descriptive we can be, especially
when we first start, right? We lack the
knowledge to actually articulate the
problems, right? I'm trying to explain a
visual medium and a visual problem with
text. Inherently, there's some loss
there. So, what can we actually do?
Well, we need to start showing Claude
code the problems. We need to start
showing Claude code actual examples of
what we're trying to push for, right?
So, to unlock level three, right, that's
where we start moving away from just
text prompts and we start moving into
the visual medium, right? we start
showing it, not just telling. And so
level three is where you become the
visual director. This is where we begin
to give claw code concrete examples of
what we are shooting for, right? That
way we aren't just relying on text and
skills. We're now going to use text plus
skills plus visual examples. Now, this
is a huge unlock for two reasons. One,
Cloud Code's obviously going to be able
to better mimic an image that you show
it versus your description of the image.
But secondly, because we are using
images, that implies that we're looking
at other websites and we are now going
to be able to see again what Wright
looks like. What are actual pros in the
space doing and how can we mimic them?
Now, there are a number of places where
you can find inspiration for your
front-end designs. And I'll list four of
them. The first one is awards. That's
awards with three W's. This is a place
where people submit their front-end work
and they get graded on it. So, it's very
much has a creative bent to it. Secondly
is godly. website. It's an infinite
scrolling website where you can just
again see a bunch of different designs.
Number three is Pinterest, which
surprisingly has some pretty cool stuff.
So, here I'm just looking for SAS
landing page. When I find one I want, I
can also see a bunch of similar ones as
well. And then lastly, we have Dribble.
That's dribble with threebs. Here I just
put SAS landing page. And again, I'm
seeing a bunch of different stuff that
looks pretty cool. Let's say and land it
on a website like Open Hands that I
like. I like sort of the, you know,
scrolling thing they have on the top
with the proven workflows. I kind of
like the different color scheme. It's
something unusual right away. They have
the social proof and just in general,
I'm liking the style, right? For
example. So again, what I'm going to do,
very, very simple. I'm just going to
take a bunch of screenshots of this web
page, dump it into cloud code, and say,
"Hey, this is the visual style I want to
move towards." So inside of Claude Code,
I said, "Actually, I want our website to
match the style of open hands." I gave
it the URL and then I said, "Here's some
screenshots for reference." And I
dropped all the screenshots in there.
And so now it has actual visual
references to go off of. It'd be kind of
difficult for me at least to describe in
words what I was looking for here. Even
with the help of something like the UIUX
Pro Skill. And it's through this process
we're going to begin to curate really
good visual references. There's so many
of them out there. And once you begin to
see them more and more and more, stuff
like this is just a complete and total
turnoff. And it's like, why would I ever
do anything like this when all this cool
stuff is available? And as you see more
of those references, even though we're
just giving Claude code screenshots,
this is going to help you communicate
what you do specifically like because
you're going to see the same things over
and over again as you look through all
these references. And what you also are
going to want to start doing is
combining references from multiple
sites, right? Even though we were using
Open Hands here, there's probably some
cool stuff I found on Pinterest or
godly. I'm like, let me pull this from
here and let me pull this from there.
Right? I want to take the best of all
these different sites and combine it.
However, it's very easy to get stuck in
this particular trap on this level. And
I would say most people kind of stop
here at level three where they
understand, yeah, I got to use skills.
Cloud code sucks off the bat, but with
skills and with screenshots, I can get
pretty far. The truth is there is a
ceiling here because we're kind we're
going to get kind of stuck at the vibe
gap like you're going to see with what
it comes out with. It's going to be like
kind of close, right? But it's not going
to be perfect because again there's
still that effect that like lossy effect
of me telling claude code which is very
much right it does everything in code
showing it a visual image and saying hey
translate the visual to code and that's
kind of the problem with a lot of
front-end design. It's like it's a
visual medium yet I'm trying to type it
out to text yet at the same time if I
throw it visual screenshots there's
still that translation piece like how
does it actually do it properly? Well,
the truth is it has a limit. And we can
see that limit in action right here
because this is what it created with all
those screenshots. Here's the original.
Here's ours. And like I've said in the
past, like this is where people get
stuck. Cuz if we scroll through this,
like, you know, if you squint your eyes,
you can kind of see what it was going
for. And it maybe got like 50% of the
way there. And there's some things we do
like. But what people do now is they're
just going to go here, take another
screenshot of the hero. Okay, let's work
on the hero piece over and over and over
again. A bunch of prompting. All right,
go back. Screenshot, go back. And it
just takes forever and you never really
nail it, right? Because it's that issue
with the translation from screenshots to
code. And so to move out of level three
and start moving on to level four, we
need to not only look at the surface of
these websites we like and grab
inspiration from them, we need to learn
how to actually clone them properly and
actually get the underlying code that is
powering something like open hands. And
this goes beyond simply just like, oh,
we just want to clone it and we're just
like copying them. No, the process of
cloning it and then figuring out how to
actually copy these things comes with
some huge benefits for us. Not just due
to the templating piece, which is great,
but you are going to then get exposed to
the actual like code that is happening
beneath the surface. And so to move from
level three to level four, we now have
to go beyond simply the surface level of
looking at these websites for
inspiration with the screenshots. We now
need to learn how to go below the
surface, look behind the curtain and see
how these websites are built in terms of
their actual coding components, their
HTML, their CSS, and their JavaScript.
And so level four is the cloner. This is
where we learn by stealing from the
pros. Now, let me be very clear. This
level is not about, oh, we're just going
to go plagiarize websites and copy and
call it our own. That's not the case
here. What is the case is we are going
to find websites that we like and we are
going to deconstruct them and then use
them as a template that we build upon
and in the process of doing so we are
going to learn a ton just like any skill
in any domain. How do you get better at
it? You see what the pros do you try to
copy them you learn a ton by trying to
emulate them and over time you give it
your own spin and you create something
original. That's what this level is all
about. And so to really get the most out
of this, we kind of need to begin to
understand what's going on with
front-end design. Front-end design to
make it kind of simplified has like
three parts. It has the HTML. Think of
that is like the bones of the website,
right? How it's actually structured. We
have the CSS that is like the styling,
right, of the website. Think of it as
the close on the website. And then we
have JavaScript. Think of JavaScript as
like the muscles, right? It's what
actually allows things to happen when
you click a button or do whatever. And
it is by looking at these three parts of
a website that we are a going to be able
to better clone or template a website,
but b understand how they work. Right?
That whole idea of deconstructing the
website and learning how they do things.
So how do we do this? How can we
deconstruct for example open hands?
Clearly screenshots don't work because
this is not the same thing. Well, it's
relatively simple. So to grab the HTML,
we're just going to go to the website
and then do control. What you see here
is the entirety of the HTML. So, what
we're going to do is we are going to
copy this, right? We're going to copy
this whole thing and then we're going to
paste it into cloud code. Now, this will
usually be rather large. In this case,
it is 1,152 lines of HTML. Now, at the
very very bottom of this, you can see
that there are also links to the CSS
files as well as the JavaScript. And
that's what I'm highlighting down here.
Now, this is going to be at the bottom
of essentially all of these HTML files.
And I'll kind of zoom out. It's kind of
hard to see, but at the bottom, right,
we have the JavaScript as well as the
CSS. So, these are actual files that
also include a ton of code. So what we
are going to do is after we give it the
HTML we're also going to tell cloud code
hey take a look at the JavaScript and
take a look at the CSS to really
understand what's happening. So I wrote
take a look at the CSS and JS files as
well. Now you can stop here and it will
use web fetch on its own to take a look
at those. The problem is the way web
fetch works is cloud code does webfetch
it calls a smaller model to do it for
it. Right? So this instance of cloud
code doesn't actually go to that web
page. It uses a smaller model. The
smaller model takes a look, it
summarizes it and gives it back to cloud
code. The issue with that is the CSS and
JS files are pretty large and they
contain again like a lot of the very
specific ways this website was put
together. So, we want all of it, right?
I don't want a summary of these files.
So, what I have done is I have created a
skill that allows Cloud Code to do this
better. It's essentially an enhanced
prompt. So, it grabs as much as the CSS
and the JavaScript as it needs. So I
just say use the site tearown skill. Now
I will put this site tearown skill
inside the free school community and
link to that is in the description. So
you just have to load that up and you'll
be able to do this as well. And so in
total what did I say? I said here's the
HTML for openhands. Take a look at the
CSS and JS files as well. Use the site
tearown skill and use this info to
better clone the original OpenHands
site. Now how is this going to educate
us? Well, first things first. You
probably have no idea like how I was
able to do things like this background,
right? You probably don't really
understand or even know what sort of
vocabulary you should have used to have
it better mimic this. Right? When we
just gave it screenshots, we got this
like, you know, kind of sort of close
thing. But by having Claude Code
actually look at what's going on under
the hood, we can now rely on Claude Code
to teach us these things. Because now
that Cloud Code actually understands at
a coding level what's going on, we can
now have an intelligent conversation
with Cloud Code and say, "Hey, how did
they do this? What does that mean? What
is a GAF? Like, how did they do the
scrolling animations? How do they do
this? How do they do that?" And over
time, after you clone more and more of
these websites and use them as templates
for your own thing, because again,
you're always going to put your original
spin on it. You're just using this as
like a baseline foundation, you will
become better at front-end design, just
like you do with any other skill. And
this is the process by which you are not
only exposed to but begin to bring in
pro techniques into your builds but to
move on to the additional levels like I
said you can't just be you know a monkey
at the keyboard with cloud code just
like with everything else we've talked
about can't just hit accept accept
except next next because how do you
differentiate yourself so what skills do
we need to master in this process we
need to learn to read and understand the
source code cloud code helps us there
need to identify which techniques equal
each effect because at a certain point
we kind have to be able to see these
websites and kind of recognize right
away like, oh, this is what's happening.
And lastly, we need to learn how to
adapt these clone patterns to our own
designs, right? We're not plagiarizing.
We're getting inspiration. And if you
don't master these skills, you're going
to get stuck in this trap, right? The
clone ceiling. You're just going to
copy, but you can't create. You're not
going to understand the why. And so,
you're going to hit a hard limit. And I,
at the end of the day, could replace you
with any dude off the street and just
tell him to do steps one, two, and
three, right? that won't get you as far
as you want to go. So, let's see what
Cloud Code was able to build when we
gave it all this additional coding
context. And here is the updated
version. And this one obviously looks a
lot closer to the original, especially
now that the background is actually
looking. So, if we compare these two
now, obviously it is a one for one just
yet. This was essentially its first
pass, but much better, much closer to
what we had. And if we want to continue
to iterate at this point and bring it
closer to whatever we like here, well,
that's much easier, right? Because now
it's looking essentially at the same
cookbook open open hands is looking at
and we can say, "Okay, let me change
this. Let me change that. I see how they
did it. Here's how we can emulate it."
Right? And again, this is where we can
begin that education process. For
example, like this cool background, how
was that working? And also how can we
get the same thing open hands has where
the mouse scrolls through and you know
sort of eliminate some of it. And all
you have to do is ask cloud code how's
the background working? How can we match
that effect? And every time you do this
you're just adding another tool to your
toolbox. And so cloud code explains how
this effect works. And better yet it now
does the proper thing on our own
background. Right? Pretty sweet. But for
obvious reasons we don't want to sit in
level four. We don't want to just be a
cloner. Right? We want to put our own
spin on it. We want to begin to make
this ours. How do we do that? How do we
begin to move on to level five and put
our own twist on things? Well, this is
where we begin to have fun with
components and also our own custom asset
designs. This is where we bring in our
own stuff and we're no longer just
copying exactly what some other website
is doing. Now, one of the easiest ways
to begin doing this is finding quality
components on websites like 21st. So in
many ways this is similar to how we
found inspiration for websites and
bringing in those parts but at like a
micro level on a component level. So on
a place like 21st.dev for example I can
look at things like buttons over here on
the left. And what I'm going to get is
like a bunch of different essentially
button designs. And if I find a button
design I like let's say you know
something like this. Well, then I can
just copy this prompt, bring it into
Cloud Code, and say, "Hey, let's
integrate this button design." And this
applies to essentially any sort of
button, right? We have stuff for
carousels. We have stuff for scroll
areas, maps, navigation, menus, images,
hooks, everything. And it isn't just
limited to 21st. We have other websites
like CodePen, right? Code Pen has a lot
of cool designs that we are able to
bring in as well. Monae is another
really cool one. And in fact, there's a
bunch of places where you can find these
sort of cool components and begin
integrating them into your web page. But
what if we want something that's a bit
more custom? I don't want to just copy a
bunch of random components I found
somewhere else. How do I really make it
original? Well, you have two options.
The first is you still use these
components from 21st.dev, but we just
prompt Cloud Code to change it, right?
It's just code. This prompt gives us the
exact code and then we can just tweak it
to our heart's desire. Or we can
literally create it ourselves. I mean,
if we head over to Pinterest and we see
cool landing pages like this that are
very like almost art forward, well,
there's nothing saying we can't use AI
to create some sort of image like this
and let it be sort of the showstopper
for when people go on our page. And
these don't just have to be still
images. I mean, we totally have the
ability to add videos to our background
to have it tied to certain scrolling
animations to again take the ideas that
we discovered in step four and make it
our own. So, let's actually do that.
Let's quickly redesign our web page. Get
away from this open hands clone and
actually design some like cool piece of
AI art and let that be what you first
see when you come onto our site. And so,
you know the drill by now. First, we
need to find some sort of inspiration.
And after scrolling through Pinterest
for a little bit, I'm seeing a lot of
sites like this where we have some sort
of almost cartoonish/stylized
image in the background for the hero
section and then we'll have some of our
text on the left. Now, this is where you
can start to bring in some of your
visual storytelling, right? What is the
app we're creating? The app is Argus,
right? And we need to come up with some
sort of tagline that ideally also kind
of ties into the image itself. Like what
are we trying to get here with Argus?
Well, Argus, you know, mythological
figure, 10,000 eyes, we're talking about
social media. We're talking about
finding things before other people do.
So, the tagline I came up with was see
what's next. Simple. It's tight. And you
know who helped me come up with that?
Obviously, it was Claude Code. And then
what I did with claude code is I pretty
much said like hey you know we're
talking about like visual storytelling
here what are some ideas we could come
up with imagery right because I don't
want to at this stage we're doing our
own thing right I can rip the you know
general concepts of what you see here
image-wise in terms of how they set
things up but the image needs to be my
own and again having some sort of visual
storytelling that ties into what your
application actually does will go very
very far. So, what I ended up doing is
then creating an image based off of some
ideas Cloud Code gave me. And I actually
leaned on MidJourney for this one. Now,
you can use any sort of image generator
you want, whether that's Nano Banana
Pro, Cadream, doesn't really matter. I
really like MidJourney for these kind of
like almost concept art type pieces
because Midjourney, especially version
seven, I really haven't tested out
version 8 very much. Like, you can give
it kind of a weird prompt. Like the
prompt I gave it was I need a background
image that will be the landing page for
a website called Argus. The tagline is
see what's next. And so just with like a
really poor um prompt like that that's
very vague. I got a bunch of cool
different stuff that I was able to
choose from. And I saw this and I was
like this looks pretty sick, right? And
I can only I can already imagine right
now like having sort of the information
over here on the left. We can have maybe
some of the stuff up top. Like I can
play with this. Like this is I think
very cool. Maybe we even do some sort of
animation at some point. So once I have
my image, it's pretty easy from there.
I'm just going to download this image,
give it to Claude Code, and say, "Hey, I
want to reimagine the hero page using
this image as the background." And so
inside of Claude Code, I said, I
actually want to change the front end
entirely. I want to use the following
image as the background for the hero.
Let's put the info about the app. Argus
on the lefth hand side, leave some
negative space on the right to show off
the image, and make the tagline. See
what's next. So we'll see what it does
at this point. point. And again, this is
kind of the level where you need to
start letting your creative juices kind
of flow because up until this point,
you've been exposed to a lot of
different front-end designs that are
different than just the super generic
stuff you see in every single SAS
template. Having some cool art,
whatever. Again, visual storytelling is
what we're going for here is really
going to level up your game. And so,
here's what our updated hero section
looks like with that brand new
background image. And I made this a
little bit smaller so you can see it in
its entirety. and Clicocom went ahead
and also, you know, updated all of the
colors. Now, again, that was just the
very first pass. All we've done is added
this background. But right away, you
start to see it feels a little bit, I
don't know, more original, more
creative, stands apart, right? And now
we begin to add more and more of our
flare to it. And to start, that can be
as simple as just upscaling this image.
You can do that inside of MidJourney
because, as we see here, the image feels
a little stretched out and not as, you
know, detailed as you would like. or we
can do something like add motion. We
don't have to have a still background.
We can actually put a video back there
as well. Now, to turn it into video is
really easy. You're just going to head
to somewhere like Clling 3.0 or VO3.1.
Just anywhere where you can do a
starting frame. Ideally, you can do the
end frame as well, like you see over
here on the left. That way, it doesn't
do some like crazy motion because you
have to remember like ideally it would
be a complete loop. Sometimes it can be
hard to get AI images to loop correctly.
So the second best option is just to
create a rather long video about 15
seconds and you want the motion to be
subtle. So kind of what you see here,
right? If I had this as a background,
even with the birds completely still,
which is totally fine. It's almost like
a parallax type thing you got going on.
And since it's the hero page and this is
lasting 15 seconds, the chances are that
someone's going to sit there for 30
seconds and see the whole thing through
are unlikely. So if there is a hitch at
the very end, you're still going to be
okay. But luckily for this one, since we
had the motion so subtle, you almost
can't even tell when it switches from
second 15 to second one. So, we're going
to use this one. And you're probably
also asking, what about performance
stuff? Well, in terms of performance on
desktop, they'll be just fine with the
video, but we will tell Claude Code,
hey, if it's a mobile, you know, user
that comes on your mobile web page, it's
not going to load the video for them. It
will just load that still image. So, I
gave it the new upscaled image and said,
"Use that for the mobile." And then I
give it a link to the video and said,
"Hey, replace that in the hero." And
here's a look at the page now with the
motion, right? I think it looks pretty
good. The other thing is it's subtle,
right? You don't want to do crazy motion
and have like a full-on video game going
on in the background unless you know
what you're doing. But something like
this with like the subtle sort of cloud
movement, you have the water moving at
the bottom, right? Again, this gives it
this gives your web page some character.
And giving your web page some level of
original character is what level five is
all about. Like I keep saying, the first
four levels, we're learning the
fundamentals. We're seeing what pros do.
Here in level five, we're actually
customizing it. So, just like you did
with the hero, that's how you need to
begin to approach every other section,
right? Like these cards. These cards are
hideous. The background here is kind of
boring. It's the same exact thing every
time. So, what am I going to do? I'm
going to find inspiration. I'll go to
21st.dev. I will go to awards. I'll
bring it into cloud code. And then I'm
going to iterate, iterate, iterate until
I get it to a place I actually like.
Now, it's at this stage as you're doing
all these visual edits that you're going
to feel a little bit constrained sitting
inside of clawed code. Again, there's
always that sort of like tension between
being inside of a terminal and using
text and trying to mess with things in a
visual medium. So in step six, we're
going to start moving outside of cloud
code a little bit because it's here in
level six where we start bringing in
some outside tools that let us get even
more specific with how these sort of
visual things are coming together. And
there are a lot of tools at our
disposal. We got things like
paper.design, we got Stitch, we got
Figma, right? We got pencil.dev. This is
where you now have the ability and the
skills to bring in these outside
programs to just tinker a little bit
more. And a great one to try out because
it's very AI forward and simple to use
is Stitched. It's also free, right? This
is from Google and essentially gives us
a visual canvas to mess with front-end
design type stuff. So, what I did here
is we're not starting anything from
scratch. We're doing a redesign. So, I
gave it screenshots of our website, both
the hero page and the rest of it. And I
said, here's a look at the current web
page setup. I really like the hero. I
like sort of the aesthetic there, and I
like the colors, but I want to update
essentially the entire bottom half of
our website, right? It just feels very
flat, right? I I want to sort of bring
in sort of the imagery and colors that
we have here up top. Like, let's see
what you can come up with. So, let's
take a look at what it generated for us
for a redesign. And here's what we got.
Now, the cool thing about Stitched is I
can have it do redesigns of the
redesign. So, if I have this selected,
you can see it gets selected down below.
And I can just prompt it like any
chatbot. I can also rightclick on it and
go to variants and again change the
layout, color scheme, images, etc. Now,
since this was a redesign in Stitch and
I wasn't just building something from
the ground up, this is just an image it
created. But this is something I can
totally rightclick, copy, and then now
bring that back to Cloud Code and say,
"Hey, what do you think about this?"
Right? Again, these sort of visual
editor tools are just great for sort of
the ideation process. And again, there's
a whole bunch of them. Pencil.dev is
another one you're going to see all over
the place. This works really well if
you're inside of like cursor or VS code
because you can actually like have the
canvas up and edit things in real time.
So there's a bunch of tools in the space
and more coming onto the market like
every week. And so I dropped that image
back in the cloud code and pretty much
said, "Hey, what do you think about
this? What do you think this sort of
glass morphism effect we got going on
with the image in the background? Let's
try that out." And that's pretty much
what you're going to do from now until
the website is where you want it because
this is the stage in front of design
where now you're just tinkering. You're
going to tinker, tinker, tinker, tinker.
By now you've built the skills to see
like what you're kind of moving for. But
this is just an extremely iterative
process. There's no real shortcut here.
But again, you have all the tools at
your disposal now, both to find
inspiration and to actually play with.
So after about 20 minutes of tinkering
on my own, this is what I got with
Argus. So first of all, you will notice
a few small changes that give it some
weight, give it a more premium feel.
First of all is the loading section.
Right? When I refresh this, what do you
see? You notice sort of like a
hesitation before all the text loads in.
It gives it some weight, right? It makes
it feel heavier. You'll also notice I
changed the fonts. Fonts are huge.
Typography is huge. Where can you go to
see different fonts and sort of like,
you know, get some inspiration? Well, a
great place is Google fonts. They have a
bajillion fonts. They're all for free.
They're broken down by different type.
And Cloud Coach can use all of them. So,
definitely check out Google Fonts if
you're like, I don't really know which
one I should use. We added a scroll
section down here. We added this sort of
ticker at the bottom that also doubles
as sort of a border between right our
video and then our image background down
here. Before we had this border going
from a video hero section to the same
image as the background was very
jarring, but this gives it a nice sort
of natural border. You will also notice
the changes that we brought in from
Stitch. We now sort of have this glass
morphism effect that we still need to
edit a little bit. You will notice it
can get a little cut off when it
bounces, but it again kind of shows off
that background artwork that gives our
thing some character. And then you can
also see some subtle things, right? If I
refresh right here, you will notice the
counter just like zooms up from 0 to 10
million. I mean, these are these nice
little like on the margin things that
show you actually cared about the
website and at some level of like
professional pride. You'll even notice
sort of like this lighting zoom go over
like AI tools and content strategy. And
again, it's just these little things.
It's these little small things that
truth be told, most people won't even
actually notice at all. Yet, when you
combine all of them, what you eventually
get is something that looks coherent and
something that you cared about and
created. Whether or not you used AI as
the tool, the point is it was crafted,
right? It's got just like all those
little things. I mean, like even like
the scroll bar up top, right? You see
how that progresses again? It's just all
these little little things. And so, how
did I prompt this? Well, I mean,
frankly, it was just a combination of
everything we talked about up until now.
Like, I've seen the kind of things I
like. I take screenshots of those and I
bring them into Clawed Code. But even
more so, like I'm no expert in web
design. So, what I did on certain
things, like I knew right away, like,
hey, like I I like the glass morphism
cards we saw in Stitch, right? Cuz
remember Stitch kind of gave us this
idea first. And when Claude Code
originally made them, they were just
kind of flat, right? They didn't have
any of this like pop off the page. So, I
said, "Hey, like let's give them some
weight. Let's have them pop off the
page. But what I also told Claude, what
I also told Claude Code was, hey, what I
want you to do is I want you to do a web
search for the best web design practices
when it comes to doing these sorts of
things. And on top of figuring out, hey,
how do we want to like make these cards
sort of pop and give them some weight,
come up with some other things that can
make our website look a bit more premium
yet in a subtle fashion? I came up with
a bunch of different ideas. I had it run
through all the ideas. Some I discarded,
some I kept. But that's sort of the
general, you know, cadence of doing
this, right? You don't have to rely
completely on yourself. Claude Cook can
go out there on the web and again see
best practices. But remember, you are
always in control. You are in the
driver's seat. And don't be afraid to
kind of have fun with this. Like I said,
all these little things, this is where
you again give it character. And this is
where you make it yours, right? The more
we can make it yours and reflection of
your creative spirit in this space, the
better it's going to look. Right.
Truthfully, because if it is a
reflection of you and what you want on
the screen and what you're trying to
portray, it's hard to really call that
AI slop. It's hard to call that an AI
template cuz it's yours. And so while
this level is on the surface about hey
using these outside tools like stitch I
think really this level six is pretty
much everything I just said like using
these outside tools like stitch to
iterate. But ultimately at this level
this is where you're finally able to
sort of I think creatively express
yourself in the front-end design space
and using cloud code as the tool versus
in the first couple levels we were just
along for the ride. That leaves us with
the final layer layer seven right and
what is going on there? What is this
stuff about 3D? Well, spoiler alert.
This is like a place where none of us
are probably going to be playing it at
all. Right? When we talk about the
frontier and the architect and 3D stuff,
this is where like the big leagues play.
This isn't really something we are going
to be able to do. I think as of today,
March, you know, late March 2026. I
don't know if this is really in our
wheelhouse yet because this is when we
start talking about things like custom
WebGL and shaders and 3D experiences.
This is when we're talking about like
websites that pretty much look like a
video game. I mean, take for example
this website right here. Do you think
this is something where we can just do
control u a you know take a look at the
HTML and the CSS and see what's going
on?
No. No. No. This is all this is like
art, right? This is a team of designers
that spent a long long time putting this
all together and it is absolutely
gorgeous. Now, in theory, could AI do
this? Maybe. But I will be honest, this
is like this is so far beyond you or me.
And I frankly just put this in here to
kind of show you what's possible because
when you see some websites like this,
and if you want to see more of them,
head over to awards, which I talked
about earlier, and go to like their
sites of the day and sites of the month,
they all like have the same kind of
thing going on where it's like this is
all custom type stuff. And maybe this is
something AI will allow us to play in in
a few years time, but like it's really
cool. like the the whole website design
space is just so interesting. This stuff
is like straight up art. And like I
said, when you first get started in the
space, you just see the same SAS stuff
over and over and over over again. But
when you see stuff like this, your your
mind is just kind of blown. And so this
is very much level seven. Uh if you know
how to do stuff like this with AI, like
hey, you should be the one on YouTube
making videos cuz I would love to learn
how. But just I purely made this level
to honestly show off this igloo website
cuz it's so cool. So, um, definitely
check it out and like just kind of have
your mind blown and let it kind of think
about what you could do in the future.
And so, this is where I'm going to leave
you at the end of our seven levels of
front-end design with cloud code. What I
hope you got out of this more than
anything is sort of the idea of the
progression of the skills to get to
something like this because it's
something that's totally doable. And
it's the idea that first we need to see
stuff we like, then we need to learn how
to deconstruct it. That whole idea of
cloning websites, I think, is super
super important, right? Because you're
going to learn so much by essentially
having Claude Code walk you through how
someone else created a website you
loved. And through that process, you're
going to get educated on all these
different techniques and effects of that
you didn't even know were possible. And
through that process, you can then go to
your own website and begin to apply
those in your creative style. Right?
That's what it's really all about. What
it's not about is like, hey, there's
this one super special skill and you use
a special skill in clawed code and wow,
look at the website. Like, truth be
told, if it was that easy, everyone's
website would look good. Everyone's
website does not look good. So, clearly
it's not that easy, right? There's a
little bit more to it. I mean, I think
the whole idea of taste and AI not
having taste, I think that's kind of
true, but I think more accurately is the
idea that we have a very tough time
articulating our taste. and we have a
tough time articulating our taste
because we don't even know the correct
words to use because we aren't web
designers. We don't know the vocabulary.
We don't know the nomenclature. And
that's actually really common thing with
s like all the AI stuff in general, not
just web design. Um that goes for like
any sort of coding stuff too. Like if
you don't come from the space, you just
don't know how to speak the language
literally. And so that creates sort of a
translation, you know, disadvantage
between you and cloud code and the end
result becomes something sloppy and
generic. But hopefully kind of going
through this road map, you see a path
forward to alleviating some of those
things over time. So hope you got
something from it. I had fun doing this.
Um, let me know in the comments what you
thought. As always, make sure to check
out Chase Plus if you want to get your
hands on the Cloud Code Masterass. We'd
love to have you there. and I'll see you
around.